see youtubers is Charlie so everyone
freaking out about the episode eight
titled the last Jedi wondering if
they're going to kill off Luke Skywalker
there are a couple big reasons why I
think that they will in a couple reasons
why I think that they won't so I'll try
to address both sides of that argument
and they also tease a little bit about
the future of the Skywalker family
relative to the saga film so I'll
explain that at the end of the video
there is a new round of the Star Wars
giveaway it's for IMAX gift certificates
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so the Star Wars people are always
intentionally vague about the new films
just to try and hold back as many
details as possible but based on the
trajectory of the new films in the
future of Star Wars movies in general
after this Sokka
you can make a few guesses on what's
going to be happening with the Skywalker
family especially in this new trilogy
but there are a couple big reasons why
they would kill off Luke Skywalker in
this next film and then a couple why
they would not so I'll try to address
things on both sides so number one
reasons why they would is the title the
last Jedi hints at him in a couple of
the International posters the language
was made singular mail so even if Rey
were in training to be a Jedi it would
have been plural in all the posters all
around the world but the problem is is
that they were trying to be ambiguous
with the title like they want people to
wonder oh is Jedi plural or is it
singular that's the whole idea but it's
really hard to do that in all the
languages around the world and even if
you go by the episode 7 title crawl
which names Luke the last of the Jedi he
was the last of the Jedi before the
force awakens in Rey so even though the
evidence does point to Luke being the
last of the Jedi there's still a number
of arguments that you could make that
it's a plural meeting but number two
Luke Skywalker is the de facto obi-wan
Kenobi of this new trilogy his
relationship with Rey is almost the
exact same relationship he had with
obi-wan Kenobi in the original trilogy
why isn't master teaching new recruit
about the ways of the force Luke and Rey
are very similar characters but they're
not the exact same he required like
little more prodding from obi-wan when
they were on Tatooine come with me to
Alderaan Luke learn the ways of the
force no I can't do that I've got the
harvest I've got all these
responsibilities after pushing Luke over
the precipice teaching him a little bit
about the force he became a force ghost
himself and even though they Bree
contextualized what it means to be a
force ghost what the rules of being a
force ghost is he still went away
leaving Luke Skywalker on his own and
there was a lot of adventures that Luke
went on between Episode four in Empire
Strikes Back
that they deal with in the Marvel comics
that they've started publishing again so
if you want to read about those they
pick up like right after episode four
Luke has all kinds of run-ins with Vader
before he meets him in battle during
Empire Strikes Back completely
recontextualizing that final moment
where he tells him he's his father so
there's just a very big period where
Luke knew a little bit about the force
but hadn't gotten any more training
the reason the movies were able to get
away with that was because Yoda still
existed in older wiser master that luke
ago continued his training with and
they've implied that that does not exist
in the new Star Wars films like the way
that opening tell across if you take it
at its face value Luke is the last of
the Jedi Snoke is like the last
remaining person on the dark side of the
force even though he's not fit so even
though there's probably holocrons
there's artifacts that you could
probably dig up there are the only two
masters that you can go seek out ask
questions and get good answers from you
could point to Maz Kanata and say that
she's the Yoda like figure of Episode
seven I think that was part of the
intention because she seems like she
understands a little bit about the force
but they don't say that she's force
sensitive or that she has any real deep
knowledge of the force just in the way
that Donnie yen's character believes in
the force and seemingly uses it without
totally understanding what's happening
number three the most damning evidence
that Luke might died during episode
eight is that he himself has been
searching for the true purpose of the
force not the truth of the Jedi thought
the Jedi Order thus if teaching things
that were not the original intentions of
the force the force has a will of its
own people misinterpret things all the
time that seems like what the writers
the producers were telling us with
Episode seven Luke and Snoke are both
trying to learn the truth of the force
obtained lost knowledge and become
something different than the force
faction before obviously they didn't
explain a lot of that in Episode seven
in really clear terms but you learn a
little bit more about that in the
expanded material something about
snoke's path but they also try to be
very ambiguous with those kinds of
details just to allow the other film to
deal with that first and then you'll get
like all the technical books like Pablo
Hidalgo publishes a lot of technical
books he also gets a lot of weird
complaints from people but he only
writes those after they decide what the
story of the movies are going to be so
on the other side of that there are a
couple big reasons why they would not
kill Luke off right away one they made
you wait through the entire film just to
meet him there was very little forced
training or even an explanation for what
was going on he didn't even speak just
very concerned looks at the sight of
Anakin Skywalker's lightsaber so even if
you haven't been listening to the rumors
from behind the scenes everything is
pointing towards him having a much
bigger more active badass role in Obi
one had in the original trilogy think
about that cantina fight how brutally he
cut down Ponda Baba in Cornelius it was
so much fun to see them in rogue one
knowing what would be happening to them
in short order but I think we'll all be
getting a Luke version of what obi-wan
did during the course of Episode four
which is way way cooler so there will be
a lot of things that are similar to
Luke's original training in Episode four
just like the early steps into forced
training but I'll explain in a second
why I think that episode eight will not
be a complete retread of the original
trilogy the way that people feel like
Episode seven was number two next big
reason there is no Yoda to continue
raised training if Luke died presumably
she's becoming this new type of force
user that isn't necessarily a Jedi but
isn't a Sith is something more complete
you could choose to think of her as a
grey Jedi that's a whole other video
that I should probably do but the
reasons that Luke was able to finish his
training become a Jedi was
because of Yoda in older wiser master
whether not obi-wan wasn't able to
complete his training this goes back to
the rules of being a force ghost
because if obi-wan was a force ghost why
didn't he just completely training
himself well one because Yoda was a
wiser more powerful master so of course
you would seek out the smartest person
available but two they also implied that
there are a lot of limitations to being
a force ghost you can't just hang around
all the time constantly in the way you
would need to if you were training
someone to become a Jedi
so if Luke became a force ghost during
episode eight he could still talk to Ray
but he wouldn't be able to train her in
the same way were he physically there
all the time I know a lot of people will
point to the idea that what if Rey were
to seek out Snoke eventually to finish
some of her training there's a lot of
evil Rey series I even did a video about
her being pulled to the dark side of the
force attending any hidden masters that
are hiding out in the galaxy somewhere
they're just nobody else to fulfill that
role in the way that Luke Skywalker
needs to so he just absolutely necessary
until she finishes her training so
number three the last reason and
probably the simplest reason for not
killing them off right away is that it's
just a complete retread of Episode four
you know Luke shows up gives us some
training boom dies off goes away never
to be seen again until we learn about
forest ghosts the problem with the new
film is that you already have all this
information about what's possible the
way the force works so part of the
really exciting stuff that I think we're
going to see is in recontextualizing the
force and what is actually possible so
you will see a lot of new things so even
though you know that it's Luke dives he
could become a force ghost I think we'll
get some new information and see some
new force abilities that will change the
way you feel about that everything
everyone has said about Episode eight so
far is that it is going to be the most
different new saga film that you could
imagine the way it's treating character
work not just the force users like Rey
and kylo Ren
but the supporting cast like Finn Poe
general Hux even Captain phasma they
said you know Captain phasma
one of the standout characters of
episode 7 please tell us there's no
captain
asthma in JJ Abrams the producers like
oh yeah there's going to be a lot more
captain phasma episode 8 but I do expect
the film's to follow like standard
Joseph Campbell hero's journey
progression but not in the cut-and-paste
way that previous Star Wars movies have
done mirroring the old films so there
will be a lot of familiar things but in
reality it'll actually be quite
different the way the plot works out
whatever the story ends up being and
then there's this implied treasure hunt
aspect of the movie that they didn't
really address after episode 7 came out
but that they teased with Rey's
flashback visions where kylo Ren is
trying to track down some secret
artifact with the Knights of Ren here so
that's something that will play out over
the course of episode a you have to
remember that the force visions that Rey
got were of the past you know things
that might be happening in the future to
the really good metaphor to make is that
the force is kind of like the Speed
Force on the flash TV show in that it's
sort of a nexus of space-time so you can
be seeing things from the past from the
future things from alternate realities
depending on the choices that you make
the future is always changing but part
of the fun is in trying to interpret
that intent like what did these actually
mean so I do not think that they're
going to kill Luke Skywalker off right
away but I do think that eventually
because of the direction that the Star
Wars movies are heading after the new
Saga film that he will eventually die
whether or not it's in episode 9 or
sometime after that but they are talking
about doing new saga film new films with
the new characters even if they're not
going to be doing saga films anymore
that will go well past the new trilogy
so like Ray would come back for some
other spin-off Star Wars movie way way
down the road so the idea is is that the
Skywalker family will no longer be the
central focus of Star Wars films in the
way that it has in the past there will
always be Star Wars films they'll always
be Skywalker's appearing in Star Wars
films but the saga films have always
been about their family in episode 8
episode 9 are the last films that are
supposed to be doing that so I'll talk
more about rey force training you know
what the future of this new type of jedi
is in the Star
universe later this week but please
leave all your requests for Star Wars
videos in the comments below what I'll
probably do is I'll be doing a couple
Star Wars videos a week for the next
couple weeks but we can make like
Friday's a Star Wars day like a day
where I always do a Star Wars video no
matter what's going on congratulations
to the latest giveaway winner Tyrone
Belin you went to IMAX give certificates
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round
that started in this video I'll just
announce the winner the next time I post
a Star Wars video so that'll be all
about rays training that will either
post on Thursday or Friday well you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
for all the episode 8 title Easter eggs
and you can click here to listen to kylo
Ren talk about his character in episode
8 Thank You Nico many watching everybody
not bad I'll see you guys me me me me me
me
[Music]
you